uh hi everyone uh hi bakker
how are you sam i'm doing well i'm doing
well
how about yourself good luck
okay so we'll be starting um
welcome everyone to another pi data real
webinar
where we are honored to be joined by abu
bakr abu to talk about building a visual
interface
for machine learning models with radio
i'm daniel dossery and i'll be
before handing it over to abu bakr i
just wanted to firmly introduce you and
mention some of
your amazing achievements for everyone
um
abu bakr is a phd student at stanford
with an undergraduate and graduate
degree from mit
for over a year now abubakar launched
his new company gradio
where he aims to make machine learning
models more reliable and effective in
academic and business settings
the session will last for 15 minutes
with the last 10
10 minutes dedicated for q a but do not
hesitate to drop a question in the q a
section as abu bakr will be
happy to answer any questions during the
session
so um without further ado abubakar
the stage is yours i'll be making you
the host now
all right let me see if i can go ahead
and share my screen
uh can you allow me to share my screen
here uh
okay i can do it now wonderful thank you
so much for the introduction dania
it's really uh it's really my pleasure
to be here with all of you today
i know it's pretty late over there in
riyadh right now so thank you so much
everyone for coming out um and thank you
so much for the kind introduction dania
so as daniel dania mentioned i'm going
to be talking about
building better machine learning models
um
using this thing that we built called
gradio so this work came out of my
research
at stanford as well as now it's spun out
to be a company gradio as well
and as dania mentioned i would love for
this to be an interactive session
so i'm going to try to make it
interactive on my end but feel free to
come
in and ask any sort of questions
throughout you don't have to wait till
the end
okay all right let's jump into it so
what i'll be talking about i'll be
talking about three things first i'll be
talking about why we actually built
gradio
what is the problem that we're trying to
solve the second i'll show you
concretely how
gradio works by walking through by
walking through
a a notebook a python notebook where we
actually use gradient practice
with a few simple machine learning
models and then finally i'll show
a real life real world case study that
we did with gradio
at stanford in an application of machine
learning to cardiology
all right let's jump into it um so one
thing i will mention
is that your feedback is is really
valuable
and if there's any sort of ideas or
additional feed
features that would be helpful for you
to go work
let me know um this is still an active
you know library in development
and so i really want to hear uh i really
want to hear
you know any sort of new features or new
additions that you have in mind
that would be useful for your work okay
um all right
so i'm going to start off by making a
claim that i think is is pretty you know
if you're following recent trends in
machine learning you've probably heard
this
uh machine learning has a
trustworthiness problem
okay and uh let me just share a few a
few articles that i've you know seen
over the span of just one month actually
this is an article that came out in the
mit technology review
this is how ai bias happens and why it's
so hard to fix
this is another article also in the mit
technology review talking about how
machine learning is contributing to a
reproducibility
crisis here's another one
talking about the explainability problem
in machine learning
and finally another one talking about
the reliability or lack of reliability
that machine learning methods often have
when they're applied to the real world
okay so
as you see these articles or as i see
these articles you know a question that
i'm thinking is
is the media overhyping this problem
right i think we've all seen examples of
you know the media creating an issue or
maybe there isn't an issue
um is this an example of that
i actually don't think so um i think if
anything the issues of bias and
and these other issues that i've brought
up are actually under explored
um here's a here's an example that
actually came out of our lab
we were looking at a state-of-the-art
image classifiers
um trained on imagenet um so
uh this is you know these are as i
mentioned state-of-the-art image
classifiers
used by many you know many companies
behind the scenes facebook
you know google are using these kinds of
image classifiers to make all sorts of
decisions
and what these image classifiers do is
they take an image and then they predict
a single class or multiple classes that
the image can fall into
so in this case uh the image on the left
is
of a bride taken in the west and the
image classification system
prints out things like bride dress woman
things that you actually wanted to
product predict most
probably um on the other hand
on the right you have an image of a
bride uh taken uh
taken in pakistan or india where i'm
where i'm from um
and you can see that the image
classifier prints out things like
performance or costume
things that are incorrect and could even
be borderline offensive as well
here's another example that kind of
shows this um many of you guys may be
familiar with gpt3
the machine learning system that was
released by openai
that does text completion you give it
some text and then it completes the rest
of the
sentence or paragraph and here
is how gpt responds with a few different
prompts
when you prompt it with two muslims this
phrase you can see that it predicts very
violent texts
if you continue priming it with other
things
two muslims walked into again it
continues
priming it with very violent text you
could try
you you could try feeding in whatever
you want to try to make it seem you know
to change the output of the model but
it's very hard
to actually prime it away from producing
this very violent type text
now even if you type into muslims
watching the mosque to worship
peacefully
again you know the text that is
producing is not
what most people would probably want out
of the system
so the question happens you know why uh
you know machine learning has all of
these issues that we've
identified these untrustworthiness
issues either it's hard to reproduce b
that has bias the models of bias see
that the predictions are oftentimes
unexplainable or or b or d that they're
unreliable in the wild
but i guess you know so then that
naturally leads to the question of
why is that the case why do these
problems actually happen
um and let me maybe you know a pause for
a second and just ask
if anyone has any ideas here why do
these issues happen
uh i think you are mute i'm not sure if
this is by
uh accident thanks yeah that was by
accident
uh but yeah so a couple people rightly
pointed out that it's issues of data
right so
that if the data is is biased then we
expect the model's predictions to be
biased as well
but that itself leads to another
question which is why are data sets
biased in the first place
like why did it take so long for people
to realize that
image that has these you know the image
that has these biased
data problems okay somebody else put in
something
because we are biased okay sure um but
then
on the other hand on one one so
collection techniques people brought up
different things
yeah so on the other hand you know yes
it's true that we as individuals were
all biased
but at the same time you know we as
individuals also found these sources of
bias as well
so it seems to be not i mean i think
it's
while it's accurate to say that it's oh
it's just biased data
it's worth thinking about why did it
take long so long to figure out these
issues of bias
how can we solve the human problem that
um
that results in these biased data sets
and so part of what i'm going to be
talking about is actually
uh is is is going to be addressing these
problems as well
okay so and and i'll give one more
answer as well
which is separate but related to the
issue of data
which is that my i think it's actually a
culture
problem the culture in machine learning
is that we optimize
all all of our algorithms are optimized
for let's get the
highest accuracy that we can on on the
test data set
okay we have some test data set like
okay how high can we push this number
it's not really optimized for usability
in the real world
um and there is a there is a a
distinction here for sure i'm not saying
it's necessarily an easy problem to
optimize for usability in the real world
but i'm saying that's that is not what
we optimize for and as a result we have
all of these issues
any questions here or any uh any
thoughts
yeah so to rephrase what i'm saying is
that all of if you think about it for
example you take an issue like bias or
or even lack of reproducibility we don't
bother making
models very usable because or reusable
or reproducible
because once we have this test accuracy
on this test data set
we can publish the model we can release
it or we can win that kaggle you know
competition
there's not really much effort made to
actually make it easy to reproduce
uh okay it looks like there was a
question
uh oh yeah and the reason for that comes
from the urge to publish yeah
i mean definitely that's definitely part
of it uh you know you can get away
with publishing something even if you
know i remember talking to one of my
collaborators at stanford um she had
published this great model
to predict patient uh
like motion in the icu and
there's a great she published it all the
stuff and
i remember asking her um cool you know
we should try this out like let's see if
this actually works let's deploy it
and she was like oh i would never ever
trust this in
any real icu um and that's because you
know
the the incentives to publish don't
really involve usability in the real
world
and so i think that there's an element
of that
um okay so there's a question about why
why is why does that happen and is it a
generalization issue
it is absolutely a generalization issue
uh
the the problem is that you know our
test data sets
don't have to really be represented
they're not really dynamic they're kind
of static they're fixed
they don't have to be too representative
of the real world
like if you were to you know point out
okay i think the test data set is
doesn't have these real world artifacts
that is much harder to publish than just
a paper on hey this is a state of the
art you know better model
on this test data sets so there are less
incentives to align
the test data sets with uh
generalization into the real world
yeah another thing that will another
factor in that and that's what i'm going
to be talking about later
is in a lot of settings
like what ends up happening is that the
machine learning developer is working in
isolation
they're not really as they're building
the model they're not really going out
and
giving it to a domain expert or to an
end user to test their
model okay they just they have this test
data set they're just focused on
maximizing the accuracy
and that's something we feel we should
change and that's something i'm hoping
gradio can help contribute to changing
okay yeah all right if there are more
questions you can ask
but let me let me go ahead and move
forward now
um so how does radio help with this um
and i mean i'll be honest here i don't
think radio can solve the complete
problem
but i do think that there's there are
concrete contributions that
gradio can help with and specifically so
what gradio does
is if i was to summarize in one sentence
basically gradio
lets you create web-based gui's from
your machine learning models very easily
so that anyone can
anyone whether they have technical
ability or not
can use and test your models okay so
this makes it really easy to test the
model in diverse settings
flag problematic predictions and and
collect rare data to add to your data
set
okay um rather than me like speaking
theoretically what i want to do is
actually want to
go ahead and show you guys the great
video
live you know python you can follow
along with me
in fact what i would like is i would
like to actually share this link to a
colab notebook
where you guys can actually run the
python code and actually make changes
and you know
see play around with the grader library
yourself so you guys can actually
give give concrete uh feedback
someone asked is it open source yes all
of this is completely open source
um so let me go ahead and actually share
this link in the chat group
once you click on it it's gonna open up
the collab notebook and if you guys
haven't used collab notebooks before
they're basically just like hosted
jupyter notebooks
and if you want to run a particular cell
of code you can just run like cells of
code at a time
so if you want to run a cell of code you
just click on that cell of code and you
press
ctrl enter so let me go ahead and do
that now
all right i just went ahead and sent
this so you guys should be able to now
click
on the link and you should see something
like
this now okay
okay so yeah so
i'm going to go ahead and show it on my
screen but the way i recommend you use
this is maybe minimize myself
and i'll just walk through the different
cells of code
and then as i describe then you guys can
run them and and you know edit them and
do whatever you want
um okay so this first part here
what is gradient i've already covered
that um in terms of what problem
gradio is solving i've talked about the
bias related issues
uh here's just another very interesting
example uh
there's a lot of effort now in you know
like face reconstruction algorithms
uh you you put in like a pixelated image
and it produces a higher resolution
version
the problem is that most of these uh
algorithms or most of these
these data are actually caucasian faces
and if you put in so for example if you
put in this picture of barack obama
he actually gets reconstructed as this
white guy
basically which is just very random but
in general these algorithms work better
on white faces and black faces and
that's the source of bias that again
wasn't discovered because the model
wasn't tested earlier on in real-world
settings it was tested on the small
test data
um okay let's go down to how do we
actually use gradio so
i'm gonna start off with section zero
installation so gradio is a python
package and so you can just pip install
it so again if you wanna actually run
this cell
it's going to click on the cell and do
control enter
and if you're running it the first time
you might have this message saying this
notebook was not authored by google
that's fine as offered by
a company that's completely normal so
you can just go ahead and click that
and you'll see that it's just going to
go ahead and install gradient onto
the in jupyter environment
uh okay well i'm just going to refresh
this page because for me
this jupiter notebook is a little slow
right now
connecting okay
are you guys able to uh are you guys
able to pip install this
let's see yes okay cool okay
give me one second on my end
okay well it's showing up busy for some
reason on my end and
oh maybe i should terminate this and
restart
yeah okay connected cool all right so
let me go ahead and run this now
um so yeah if you run it you should see
that it's just installing gradient
that's uh completely normal now let's
actually jump into an example
so gradio at its core basically combines
three ingredients you have one a python
function
it's the second thing you have is what
is the input ui component that you want
and the third thing is what is the
output ui component that you want
okay so let's again see a very concrete
example of this
so here i have this function called
replace
okay and all it does it takes a string
and it replaces the world
with the word world with the word real
then i create a gradio interface object
that takes in a function it takes in an
input and it takes in an output
okay and then you just do dot launch and
then share equals true i'll explain what
this is in just a second
and i go ahead and i run this code okay
so i'm going to go ahead and run this
code right now
and what this is going to do is if
everything runs smoothly
this should go ahead and
create um it might take a little bit of
a second
it might take a second if a lot of
people are using this it's fine i'm just
going to open this link
so what's happening here let me just
explain why this code is loading is that
i'm basically telling it
that the appropriate inter ui component
for the input is a text box
and the output is also a text box
so let's give it a second okay
cool so you can see here it actually
created this interface it created this
on a separate web page
and it should have done the same thing
for you it also created it right here
within the collab notebook so i don't
actually have to go anywhere
i can start writing stuff in it if i do
something like this hello world and i
submit it you can kind of imagine what's
going to happen
it basically takes this ui component
wraps it around my function and so i can
now start interacting with it
in interesting ways okay i can i can you
know start using this for demos like i'm
doing now
you can start using it for debugging too
hey interesting okay i
realize my my function is maybe not case
sensitive this is a very simplistic
example but we'll see more realistic
examples
when we when we talk about machine
learning examples um
but this is just a couple of examples
there are a lot of different
ui components that radio supports
there's a page here where we list them
all out but any
all of the common things that you can
imagine dragging and dropping an image
recording audio sliders all of that you
can actually use
to to to build an interface for your
model or for your function
any questions here before i get into
maybe a more realistic example
if not let me let me uh let me show an
mnist example now
so now that we have the core idea here
uh okay so there's a question here uh
could we use it for taking data from
other people like social media comments
um yeah so if i understand your question
right uh you can and i'll actually i'll
come back to that in just a second
that is definitely a very important use
case but i'll come back to that
so here's um here's a another example
that i've
that i've created that i'm running here
now
this here downloads a
mnist model and actually uses tensorflow
to load the model
okay and then it has this function
called recognize digit
and what recognize digit does is it
basically takes that input
input it adds a bas dimension it runs
the model's prediction
and it returns a dictionary of
predictions and their confidences
okay now the most logical input here
is a sketchpad so that's another input
that we have and i
yeah another input that we have is
something called sketchpad
now the output here i'll mention is that
rather than providing a
string shortcut i so far i've always
been using string shortcuts
but you can actually do something else
too you can actually instantiate
a gradient ui component and this
allows you to do things like customize
the ui component
so in this case i've customized it by
telling it only show me the top three
classes
even if i have 10 classes that's being
returned by the function i only want to
see the top three classes
okay and this will allow when i run this
if i launch this this will actually
create
this interface here okay and then i can
actually now run this interface if i run
this
i can literally draw different digits
and i can you know i can
see the mnist model's prediction and
that's pretty you know that's pretty
neat
one thing you can do is you can again
now start probing your model for
what are its weaknesses so one thing
that i've realized that the mnist model
is very sensitive to things being in the
center
if you say if you put things that are
not in the center you actually
can break it quite easily okay if it's
in the center then it's all good but if
it's not centered it sometimes
it makes weird predictions okay
um and and i'll talk about you know so
this is useful for finding failure
points but
once you've found failure points how do
you actually do something with those
i'll talk about that in just a little
bit
any questions here
okay if people have questions they can
ask them i'll also mention one other
pretty neat thing
that you can do you can literally take
the same thing i have over here
the recognized digit function the input
being sketchpad output
and you can just add the argument live
equals true
if you do live equals true what that
does you run this again
if you do live equals true you can
actually start seeing
predictions in real time so it's going
to take a second because after we run
this i
did about that i hadn't run that but
you'll see what that looks like in just
a second
let's open this up here easy for it to
load
one thing i will mention is right now
i'm showing this in a in a collab
notebook
but of course this actually works
anywhere you can run this in a python
script
in a your own jupyter notebook that's
running locally or on a server it
doesn't matter
it everything or on a kaggle notebook
this this really works in any sort of
environment but here for example you can
now you can do things like start drawing
and you can see you know for example at
what point did the prediction has
changed from a three
to this eight you know um does that make
sense
if there's issues then you can flag
those issues as i'll mention in just a
second
okay but you can get that just by doing
live equals true
okay any any questions
so far
okay all right in that case let me move
on
i'm going to show a different example
now with another ui component this one's
with the image
input interface and this here is the
inceptionnet model
so what i'm doing is i'm going ahead and
downloading inceptionnet
i'm going and going ahead and getting
the human readable labels
and then i just have a simple function
that basically
takes an input image and passes it
through mobile
through inception that returns a
dictionary of predictions
and then now for my input interface i
have an image object
which reshapes my image to be 299 by 299
by three
and then the label outputs the top three
classes
and then if i if i go ahead and open
this up
what this is going to do is it's going
to show me that interface and now what i
have is i actually have
an interface into my imagenet model and
i can pass in things
and see how the model will predict okay
cheetah okay that's pretty cool
one other thing that you can do is you
can start actually manipulating these
objects
manipulating these input data you can
say for example let me understand
is imagenet robust to rotations
okay so right now it's 91 percent
cheetah now is still predicting cheetah
but it's a lot less confident
you can also do things like other sorts
of perturbations that may be more
relevant for your use case
like you can say okay i want to know if
it's sensitive if it's robust to noise
let me add quite a bit of noise okay
i can get a noise and you can see that
actually it's quite
uh robust to noise you know it's 89
percent
confidence to cheetah despite this
forget the noise maybe you want to do
something like change the brightness
okay
if you want to use this model in the
dark for example i don't know
nighttime you know is it going to work
well in night time i can barely tell
it's a cheetah
and i guess for imagenet now it looks
more like a leopard
maybe leopards or night cats i don't
actually know but you can start doing
these types of things
the other pretty cool thing is that i
haven't really mentioned this but you've
noticed that this whole time i have
share equals true in all these examples
and what that does is that actually
creates a shareable link from my model
and so i can literally share this with
you guys
um uh oh thanks for who shared the
notebook yeah
so i can literally share this url with
you
uh you guys or i can share it with let's
say my you know collaborators
in the lab or i can share it with you
know on social media or something i can
say hey i've built this model
i want you guys to test it out and you
guys can literally run this you know and
and on your end you don't need any sort
of specialized hardware or software
or any sort of dependencies because all
you guys need is a browser
right all you need is a browser you open
it up and the compute continues to run
within this jupyter notebook
all right and the way it works is that
basically
on the remote users they can run this on
their laptop or on their phone
and the gradient takes care of the
message passing it'll send it
send the image to the host computer
which continues running the model
and then the host computer makes a
prediction
and returns it to the remote users
and so on your collaborators and or on
your your testers and for example they
don't need any again any sort of
specialized anything
which really opens up the possibilities
for who is able to actually test your
model
or use your model or give you feedback
you can send it to your
advisor or your colleague or to your
parents you know or
whoever you want and they can start
using this
okay and what they can do
and this is maybe the the most useful
feature and this is what somebody asked
about
is they can start flagging issues with
the model as well
so here's a for here's an example of an
out of distribution input image that i'm
putting in so this is a picture of
robert downey jr
is predicting suit and maybe i don't you
know maybe suit is not a reasonable
prediction here
so what i can do is actually i can click
on the flag button and what happens now
is actually really powerful
what happens is that this feedback gets
sent to
the host computer that's running the
model and
on that computer a directory is created
of all of the flagged input okay so you
can see here this flag directory
uh and this name of my model and you can
see here
uh this input image is so that
the the the uh there's a log file that's
created
that consists of the input data that was
flagged which in this case is this image
along with what the model predicted so
you can now you can do this and say okay
why is my model failing on this maybe i
need more
pictures of people or i can you know
take this image data point and then add
it to my model or add it to my data set
to build a better model so now like
people are actually able to give you
feedback on issues that you that that
your model is having
you know very early on immediately as
you're like rapidly prototyping you can
send this link out you can get feedback
build a better more diverse
representative data set so you can have
you know better models at the end
and so if any of you guys actually try
this out in the link that i sent you
and if you guys flag anything this
should actually show up let me refresh
this to see if anybody did that i don't
think anybody did that yet but if you
were to do that it would literally just
add it here
so that's kind of cool
so any questions about this here let me
check the chat
okay i guess uh if i may ask a question
uh you show this image input and also
text
so what other types of input like audio
video are you guys exploring yeah
all right thanks for asking that uh
let's show let's go to the next example
so one thing is that uh we support uh
different different uh different inputs
and outputs
and so i think you asked about audio and
uh and certainly we support that and
somebody else also asked about can the
output be images absolutely
uh so the question was
it can output the images where we use it
for gas um yeah in fact let me just show
somebody tweeted something uh
a really cool application in a tutorial
that they were building uh where the in
where's the cycle again and so it's the
input is an image and the output is an
image as well
and so they were using gradio to
actually demo that so
there's a lot of different input
interfaces and you can find a list of
them
on our website on the documentation page
so all of the input components are
listed here on the right on the left
and the output components are listed
here so things like audio
files data frames checkboxes sliders
it can be inputs and then the output
components similarly there's a
variety of things and you can also take
arbitrary generate arbitrary html if you
want to
do different you know fun things like
that
okay uh business model okay i'll get
back to that um
towards the end cool um
all right the another example that i
want to show is
not only do we support a variety of
different inputs you can actually
combine
inputs together to create interfaces
where
there are for example multiple inputs
into a function and so
take a look at this function here i'm
going to go ahead and
close this so this here
let me zoom in a little bit this here is
a function number four
greet which takes in three input
parameters
and it returns two output values so if
you wanna
make an inter input interface around
here
um you can if you want to create you can
actually pass in a list of input
interfaces
correspondingly each of the parameters
so here for example i wanted a text box
i wanted a check box and i wanted a
slider okay
and as the input and then for the output
i wanted a text and a number
and so you can you can test that here so
let's say i'm doing something like this
i'm putting in dania let's say
it's not morning in riyadh let's say and
what this will do is
this will say good evening it's 30
degrees today and then the output is
another number which is just the
conversion to celsius um
but yeah so you can now use this to you
know construct more complicated uis
if you want to for example have sliders
that throttle certain properties someone
mentioned gans
if you want to have like input variables
corresponding to different latent
variables
you can you can have multiple sliders uh
okay so a great question
from the privacy perspective that's
really important no none of your okay so
none of your data gets uploaded onto the
server
we don't touch any of the data this is
just a message passing thing
so we just need some sort of public url
that we can use to actually
send the data from your from your test
user
to the host user and so that's what this
is doing none of your data stored in
fact if you want
you can actually run this locally and
then set share equals to false
and then no public link is created
whatsoever so if you want to just test
it locally or demonstrate locally
you can do that as well so
an example of that well maybe i won't
show an example but if you were to just
maybe even download
this jupiter
notebook and just run it locally
download this as an ipnby file
um and run it locally you're going to
see that instead of creating public
links these are actually going to create
private links instead the reason is
creating public
links right now it's because it's
running in a collab environment
okay cool does that answer your question
yeah okay
sweet all right uh we're getting
something in the chat
can it work okay um yeah so a great
question does it work with other
libraries um so from a from a machine
learning perspective
this is completely library agnostic um
it doesn't matter if you're doing
tensorflow or pytorch or
scikit-learn as long as you have a
function
we can wrap a ui around it right so it's
completely agnostic to that
um i'm not specifically familiar with
folium
and the question was also about that can
you support maps
um so as of now it we don't have like a
map ui specifically
but we do have very generic input
interfaces
um like for example it can take in an
input file no matter what the file is
and it can output an html canvas
you know so you can put whatever you
want on it and and and
you know if it's a map that's great
whatever you want really and people have
done very creative things
there's another question but while uh
so someone raised their hand i think
okay if someone raised their hand feel
free to ask a question
but um you can really do very creative
things with it uh
we have one user who we don't even know
exactly who this person is
but um they created this really
interesting interface using gradio where
uh they it was not the best example
let's put in a
different example um let's say this
cheetah example
you can put in an input image and it
basically cuts it up into little like 16
little pieces
and it tries to reassemble it using
machine learning
it's very interesting i don't know where
they got this idea but you know the
point is here they they were able to do
whatever they want they were able to put
in a gif here and to do all of this
stuff
because you know we can make we're
pretty flexible in what we support
on the output
okay um all right did someone else have
a question
all right maybe i'll end i'll show one
more example in code and that'll be the
last of the
coding examples
so i mean this is a lot of things so i'm
not going to go through all the code you
can take a look at it
but the point i want to make is that
there's actually a lot more what gradio
can do
so here's an example where i've added
multiple models in parallel so maybe you
have two models and you actually want to
compare their predictions
so this will show that this will also
show some examples of how to add
metadata
to your model and i'll explain what i
mean by that let me just go ahead and
run this for now um
okay so while this is running let me
explain what i mean by metadata
so sometimes when you create an input
interface you want to you might want to
add a title to the web page
you might want to add a description so
that people know what they're doing and
you might even want to add some sample
images right so because sometimes
you know your users may not necessarily
have an image off the top of their
um you know on top of their mind that
they want to test but
maybe they have a you know if you can
give them them sample images they can
get started
by testing your model so this is a very
comprehensive example where we have a
title a description some sample images
and let's see what that looks like
it's taking a little bit of time to load
but
once it once it loads it's pretty fast
okay so you can see that that interface
is here it has a title
it has a description and you can now put
in one input image and you can see
both of the predictions from both of the
models mobile. versus inceptionnet
and you can see here the latencies as
well so maybe you care about that
um you can compare predictions for
something like this
and interesting what you find is even
for out of distribution images it tends
to make the same
predictions but uh or at least the top
prediction
tends to be the same and they tend to
make the same mistakes because i guess
they were both
both trained on on imagenet this is not
a tricycle but both of them say it's a
tricycle
yeah so you can add examples you can add
titles descriptions you can have these
two things in parallel
okay um all right so rather than me
like showing all of these different um
things like in explaining every single
thing
that i would like to show you guys
something called gradiohub this is
something that we created
um that has a bunch of pre-trained
models i'll send the link right now in
the in the group where is this
so i'll give you guys a second to open
that up
because this is a pretty cool thing
where you can actually try out different
oh
and if you think this is cool you're
welcome to give it a star
that way it builds it helps us build
legitimacy and it helps
uh it also bookmark it for you if you
want to come back to this later on get
out
but uh if you you can actually open up
any of these models and you can start
using them
uh immediately again from your browser
and you can put in an input image and
you can actually run this
immediately and what this is doing is
this is
again you know it's using the we've all
we've done is we've taken the gradient
uis
and wrapped them around these
pre-trained models and just making them
much easier for anybody to use now
there's another question
um yeah so there is a question here
about
can we connect it to a database uh what
do you mean by that
uh regarding privacy you said host does
yeah so the host can be
anybody it can be literally your laptop
uh it can be a server that you have on
premise
um the host can you can you know you can
get this running on heroku we have a
tutorial
um uh and so the host really could be
anybody
any any any place where you can run
python you can actually run this
uh okay when data is stored on a
database okay so great question
um so that so i'll get back to that
actually that's something we don't
currently support but it's on the
product roadmap
how can you use radio on nlp problems
sure so a lot of the examples that i've
been showing are images
but you can absolutely use this for text
as well and for other things
so we have we have some examples here
let me show
so if you're going to uh docs
you can see a lot of different examples
that we have
and a lot of different things so for
example you see some text examples here
um here's an interesting one text
analysis
uh you can see here you can put in any
sort of sentence
and then the output is passed through
spacey i think
and you can see it's we're using it to
demo a lot of really interesting things
uh like the different parts of speech uh
character counts yada yada
um how many uh you know what the diagram
looks like
you can do that with all of that with
spacing okay
so again any place where you have
existing machine learning we don't
we're not here to like change your
machine learning workflow you use your
existing tools
you know whether it's whatever libraries
you care about whatever
environment you work in whether it's
jupyter notebooks or or
python terminal you know you're writing
code in the editor and what we're giving
you
is the ability to simply wrap
really wrap a ui really simply around it
so that you can then test it share it
much more easily okay
what about nlp for arabic text we
actually have oh i wish i had that link
we have someone who is she's actually
using this to look at word embeddings in
arabic
um but yeah this is completely agnostic
to uh
language and so you can literally put in
arabic text here and
as long as your your python function can
handle the arabic text
you know it's chill it works
cool yeah thanks for all the questions
these are great questions
um let me come back so yeah
so um try out the hub
um that's that's probably the easiest
way to actually just immediately start
using
uh different models and just seeing what
you can do with gradle
and you can do you know like this is a
fun one i think if this yeah this works
this one's like surviving the titanic
you guys might have seen this from one
of the most famous kaggle competitions
but this is a live interface you can see
for example if i set a certain fare
how does my age actually impact my
ability to survive you know
how does my gender affect my ability to
survive
because you know as you guys know on the
titanic they would let
i think it was younger young and female
and
and the third and the first class
passengers off first and so you can kind
of play around with that
okay um so yeah so there's a
question yeah okay cool i'll talk about
the road map towards the end absolutely
but before i do that i want to just show
one case study
where how we actually use this at
stanford
so so my area of research and i didn't
didn't get a chance to talk about this
much at the beginning but
my area of research at stanford was
applications of machine learning to
medicine
and so a very common workflow that we
would have was
that we would be working with a clinical
collaborator
and they would basically collect all of
the data and label it and then they
would give it to us
and we would pre-process the data we
would build the model
we would test the model and then
sometimes you know when the model would
be ready we would
deploy it and give it back to the club
use but it was very segmented like when
i was building the model
there would be no input whatsoever from
the clinical collaborator
and that would lead to a lot of the
problems that i've been describing
and so what we wanted to change was this
ability to actually work more closely
with a clinical collaborator
throughout the process of of of machine
learning
specifically in the key steps of data
acquisition labeling as well as model
testing and queueing
if they could get my input on what data
to collect
and i could get their input on what how
how to test the model and qa
we would have much better real world
usage of the model
and so we ended up actually doing that
for one of the papers that we wrote
recently and this is a paper that came
out this year
in nature digital medicine about deep
learning
about deep learning applied to
echocardiograms
an echocardiogram is an ultrasound of
the heart for those of you guys who may
not know
and what we did was we had this model
that would basically take in an
echocardiogram that i'm shown on the
left
and would predict different things about
what's inside the patient's heart
and you can see here that this over here
is a pacemaker
and we would be able to predict that
there's a pacemaker inside of the heart
and we had pretty high accuracy
i've added the arrows here but you know
the arrows are usually not there
but we showed this to a cardiologist and
they were like hmm does this really work
so we wrapped a gradient ui around it
and let them play around with it
and they actually edited the image like
i'm showing like i showed you earlier
you can also use the editor to block out
certain things and so they blocked out
the pacemaker
and in real time the prediction changed
to no pacemaker
you know and the model went from you
know 70 pacemaker to 90
no pacemaker and when that happened the
cardiologist was a lot more
trusting in the model that the model
actually worked and
to be fair even the even the machine
learning scientists
us in the room when this happened we
breathe the sigh of relief too
because you can get a good accuracy but
you never really know a model is working
until you can actually you know
perturb it and and see make sure that
it's actually working
and so um this is an example of where
these radio interfaces can help build
trust
and verify that these machine learning
models are working in a robust manner
okay uh so i'll end here
i'll talk about the the product roadmap
too actually um actually let me do that
first
uh so there's a couple things that are
on the road uh
one is interpretation this is something
that we're hearing from people as well
is that we don't want to just know if
this is a can
if this is benign or cancerous but we
want to know what the machine learning
model was looking at when it's made its
prediction
so we have some really exciting uh work
going on here it's going to come out
pretty soon
hopefully by next week actually which is
going to be an out of the box
interpretation framework
you can take any model you have any
image model or any text model
and we will figure out what is you know
what what
in the input is causing the model to
make that prediction
that's pretty exciting um and we hope to
as i said unrolled that next week
another thing that's down the road
probably next month or so
or by the end of this month early next
month is being able to handle bulk input
and show embeddings so somebody asked a
question about databases
so right now one of the limitations of
gradio is it can only handle one input
at a time
we're going to be working on extending
the capabilities to handle lots of data
at once
and show the embeddings and show the
predictions so that you can explore your
entire data set at once not just one
little piece at a time
yeah so takeaways radio is a library for
interacting with trained machine
learning models and sharing them
and our hope is that it can build more
reliable models
more robust models and to use it just
pip install it
visit the website where you can sign up
for updates as we release these new
features
and yeah thank you so much for for for
everyone here
for listening and asking your questions
and taking out the time
on a wednesday evening really appreciate
that thank you so much
thank you i guess we have some
questions if you can check them out
yeah so somebody asked yeah nlp modeling
accept xf yeah absolutely that is that
is our hope uh
uh you know one of the use cases that
we've seen is
oftentimes you'll have a model and
people are sending excel files back and
forth you know full of you know
try this prediction what is it is this
correct prediction
that's not a in our opinion that's not
really a nice
way to deal with these models it would
be much nicer if the tester could simply
just run the model themselves
on whatever input data they want tweak
certain things if there's issues flag
it without the machine without having to
do this back and forth let technology do
the back and forth much more effectively
um and so that is yes that is part of
the plan
so i like this part very much it's like
taking model testing to another level so
similar to what is happening with mobile
development others
so yeah let's see if we have i think we
have another question here
that's the question here is great oh
yeah yeah okay oh yeah people asked
about the business model or even
radio is completely free and it's open
source uh you can actually
start using this right now uh uh without
without paying a dime or a real or
anything
but uh but what we in terms of what the
actual business model is
we're also simultaneously building an
enterprise version of gradio that's more
focused
towards the needs of large companies
if this sounds useful like if you want
to do a kind of large-scale testing
uh within your company if you work at a
company let us know
um we're happy to start working with you
guys uh we're we're in the early stages
so
we're actually looking for design
partners and so if this sounds
interesting for your business
let us know and we're happy to work with
you
so no hidden costs
thank you
a question on on the ultimate vision
that you have for radio
uh let's say in the near future that's
you shared with us the roadmap but was
there like a feature that you had in
mind but
you tried it but it wasn't feasible uh
at this time and you wish to tackle it
later
that's an interesting question is there
a feature that
uh is not feasible at this time but
we're planning on building out later
um yeah i mean there's uh
at the end of the day you know what what
we think could be extremely powerful
is essentially something that that
streamlines how teams work on machine
learning
so what we we see you know again and
again we've talked to so many businesses
who do interdisciplinary machine
learning
and it's just like you know the chemists
are speaking so we're talking with a
drug pharma company
and they're telling us you know it's
like the chemists are speaking one
language and the
machine learning scientists are speaking
another language and
the the the machine learning scientists
ask for data from the chemist
and the chemists don't know what data to
give and there's just this
lack of you know inter operability and
ability to actually work
effectively and you know machine
learning projects that should take you
know days
or taking weeks to months and some of
them fail because the right data isn't
being sent over and all of that
um so we would love if there's some way
to like bri you know to actually break
this
this this lack of ability to work
together
you know for lack of a better term um
but this is you know this seems to be as
much of a human problem and a
communication problem as a technology
problem
so we're still trying to figure out
exactly what that looks like we're doing
our best i think right now to tackle it
from a technology perspective
but i think there's a lot more to it and
uh just figuring out what are the best
patterns of
you know almost from like an
organizational psychology perspective
how do we get
very different teams to work together to
build machine learning models because we
look at all of the exciting machine
learning model
machine learning companies that are
starting nowadays they're always
interdisciplinary it's like
you know machine learning applied to law
machine learning you always have some
sort of domain expert whose expertise
the machine learning per person doesn't
have and so like how do we utilize
these this domain expertise effectively
i think it's such an interesting problem
um and something that currently is is
not well well understood or well solved
yeah yeah and i think especially uh not
only for researchers in terms of
trying to debug models or trying to
develop or let's say to produce the
models that they have but also in terms
of startups
trying to come up with an mvp for
whatever feature that they have
in their current products this is
extremely useful
especially like for current settings
that we have so we don't have to build
everything from
from the start that's fascinating yeah
absolutely yeah that sounds great i
don't know if you if you work at a
startup
but you know we are we are looking at uh
as i mentioned earlier some you know
design partners
and so if there's like extra features
that gradient doesn't currently have but
you know that would be helpful for your
startup
ping me afterwards uh you can reach me
out on on twitter maybe that's the best
uh that's the best way and i would love
to maybe work with you guys and you know
and brainstorm what these features
should look like
definitely okay um the question of a
data free body feature okay really good
question actually you know
that's another area to answer uh it's
related to the question i was just asked
about uh what else would we like to
include
as i mentioned you know the machine
learning workflow a big part of it is
data pre-processing
and this is another piece right now
where the machine learning person kind
of does it but
these features oh no this is an
unrealistic feature to include maybe try
this combination of features
something that allows uh
something that allows domain experts uh
subject matter experts
to give their feedback on how to
pre-process
data and select features i think would
be incredibly valuable so
that's another really good piece
actually thanks for bringing that up
any other questions
i guess that's all for
today uh thank you so much
[Music]
it's been a really insightful session
and we hope everyone enjoyed this
session as much as we did
and we'll be posting the material and
the recording on our social media
accounts so make sure to
follow us on twitter and meet up
additionally we have posted a tweet so
if you could share what you guys did
with your gradio
with the radio app if you have you if
you manage to get something out
share it with us on twitter and we'll be
sure to retweet it and
put it out in the world yeah absolutely
i'll retweet it too
yeah so that's our time thank you very
much
thank you daniel for inviting me thank
you
good rest of the day thank you